You know,
I never want to be that nine to five
person that just lives my entire life
working the nine to five and just be
happy with a modest lifestyle.
Um,
you know,
being secure.
A lot of people,
that's all they want and they just want
a secure lifestyle,
um,
you know,
own a house,
and be able to retire and that makes him
happy,
you know?
And I just believe that we should always
be,
always be pushing,
you know,
to achieve more.
It's become more,
you know,
and sit at a job.
The same job for 30 years is not
something I would ever choose to do in
the society.
You know,
we,
we are tied to go to college and get a
job.
That's what we're taught.
If you become a doctor or a lawyer,
you're successful,
you know,
but most of the time still have a boss,
so have someone you know Tony what to do
and you still have the schedule and you
have to stick to,
um,
you know,
so it's not much different than working
at Mcdonald's.
I mean,
it's just you're making more money,
but you're still on the same exact
situation.
And you know,
working at Mcdonald's is not sinking or
same scenario,
making more money,
you know,
to me,
you got to enjoy what you're doing and
you know,
to have the lifestyle freedom,
do what you want,
when you want the most incredible thing.
People don't understand it.
You got to work hard at whatever you do,
whether you're working for someone else
or working for yourself.
And if you want to put that in,
you know you're going to end up being
successful.
You can't be satisfied.
But that's what keeps us going.
You know,
when you become content,
then life's over.
Okay?
I did.
The mentality is what's going to make
things happen.
You know,
was having that mentality of never give
up,
keep pushing forward and trying to
accomplish your goals and hopefully you
have more goals,
constantly trying to move on to bigger
and better things and trying to improve
ourselves in every area.
You really have to believe what you're
doing is working.
And I was very important to believe you
have to believe to achieve.
If you're doing something,
you're not hundred percent confident
what you're doing,
you're going to fail.
You know,
someone who is doing something,
maybe not 100% correctly,
but they truly believe in their mind
that they're doing the best they could
possibly do and they believe what
they're doing is the best possible
scenario.
I think they're going to have a lot more
success than someone that is doing it in
100% right but aren't positive than what
they're doing.
You know,
the mind is the most powerful tool we
have and in order to be a winner you
have to lose.
You know,
that's,
that's how you learn.
You know,
one day I may is telling me,
you better get out there and start
busting your ass,
you know,
going forward and never stopped.
Don't miss a day.
You know,
one day miss is they can't get back.
Always.
Always look at the positive,
you know,
the glass is always half full.
Okay.
If you think positive and you look at
the positive,
you know,
you're,
you're only going to continue to get
better and it's being positive in every
area.
Is is the secret.
It's a secret to life.
If you're negative about anything,
you're going fail.
No matter what it is,
you're not happy,
you want to be better.
But that's one in every aspect.
Like you want to better yourself in
every way possible.
You know,
all work hand in hand.
A lot of people realize when you help
somebody else you're helping yourself
and it feels good,
you know?
And it just,
what comes around goes around.
The most important thing is light in
life to not give a shit what other
people think.
You know?
That's the most important thing.
And to have that kind of an attitude and
mentality is rare.
You know,
people are always concerned about what
other people think,
no matter who they are.
It really doesn't matter what other
people think,
you know?
It really doesn't matter if you can have
that kind of mentality is so much
further in life.
People don't like to think they like to
ask.
No,
they don't like to think and they don't
have enough confidence in their
decisions that they make on their own.
When they get advice from someone else,
that gives them more confidence to
believe that that's going to work.
We should always be trying,
you know,
to be better at every aspect in life.
I mean,
you know,
are you a good husband?
Are you a good wife?
Are you a good son?
You know,
are you a good,
you know,
whatever it could be.
You know,
there's a million things in life that we
are,
we,
I think we should constantly be trying
to be better in every area.
I kind of liked to just,
you know,
relax,
enjoy life and that's kind of what I do.
Um,
and being able to,
to not stress and do what I want to do
when I want to do it is just a great
feeling.